[Music]  [Music]  hello my name is dr klein  and today i'd like to discuss your  post-operative recovery  who am i why  am i here i realize that to look in the  mirror and see a stranger every day  can prove even more unsettling than the  fear of tissue rejection itself  you must remember that you are  surrounded by people that love  and support you i know why it's on and i  know  this ain't him rest assured in time they  will come to see you for who you are  now let's begin going through what you  can expect over the coming weeks and  months with your new transplant  [Music]  sometimes a little pain can help you  feel like yourself again  don't hide from your demons  you